donc je vais aujourd'hui vous présenter
un ouvrage qui mêle à la fois à la
pédagogie la sociologie et également des
questions d'actualité marie sandrine
lamoureux c'est une enseignante une prof
de français qui a toujours enseigné dans
les banlieues dans toutes les zones
qu'on appelle sensible les zones
d'éducation prioritaire et c'est dans
des établissements un peu difficile et
en réaction aux attentats de charlie
hebdo elle a voulu témoigner sur son
métier de prof dans ces zones qui sont
très mal perçue par par l'ensemble de la
population il ya plein de plein d'idées
reçues dessus et elle explique ce qu'est
être prof
dans ces conditions là et surtout quel
est le rôle d'un enseignant dans de tels
établissements que c'est ils doivent
être là pour effectivement renseigner
leurs matières mais également former de
futurs citoyens ça peut paraître un peu
bateau comme ça mais c'est c'est
clairement ça le rôle des enseignants en
banlieue et c'est ce que marie sandrine
lamoureux a expliqué la question des
attentats de charlie hebdo est
évidemment évoqué parce que suite aux
événements il ya eu des réactions un peu
disproportionné dans s'éclate il a fallu
qu'elle explique en quoi c'était du
terrorisme
enfin voilà et puis surtout qu'elle
écoute les élèves qu'elles comprennent
ce qu'ils pensaient et pourquoi il avait
de telles réactions
voilà c'est un livre qui est parfois
très drôle parce que l explique de
manière un peu brutes les réalités de
son métier mais c'est un livre qui est
aussi très instructif parce que elle
explique elle qui est prof de français
comment amener des enfants à la lecture
alors qu'ils n'ont jamais ouvert un
livre qui ne vont jamais dans les
bibliothèques ou bas ils s'intéressent
au sport et leur fait d'abord bien
l'équipe
et puis au fur et à mesure comme ça elle
va leur présenter des livres
elle organise une
bibliothèque au sein de sa classe en se
disant que je suis sur trente élèves y
en a deux qui emmène des livres chez eux
et qu'ils les feuillette voir qui est de
l'hélice déjà ça de gagné voilà c'est un
livre qui est plein d'espoir qui démonte
un peu toutes les idées reçues et tous
les mythes qu'on a sur la banlieue et
sur les autres d'éducation prioritaire
aujourd'hui je vous présente un double
album du scénariste lupano donc ça
s'appelle les communes orb donc lupano
on lui doit entre autres un océan
d'amour et puis les vieux fourneaux le
livre fournit d'ailleurs il ya un
troisième tome qui va sortir la cour
encore novembre donc là aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler surtout de ses deux
albums il y aura un troisième qui
viendra conclure cette trilogie sur la
place des femmes dans la révolution
socialiste qui a eu lieu à paris donc en
donc le premier album se situe juste
avant l'insurrection de paris c'est donc
c'est une histoire d'une petite fille et
une relation avec sa maman
donc quelle place va voir sa maman dans
cette révolution donc 1870 c'est la
pénurie de face à la famine à grande
famine donc voilà la surrection commence
à monter la révolution se met en place
et là on fait un gros focus sur la place
des femmes et leur leurs positions
qu'elles ont prises durant cette cette
révolution donc le premier album va
traiter sur l'avant 1871 et le second
album en fait c'est durant
l'insurrection c'est une disciple de
marx qui a envoyé depuis londres à paris
pour un peu mettre de l'ordre et mettre
en marche ce mouvement féministe et pour
justement impliquer les femmes au plus
près de cette révolution
outre les très beaux dessins qui sont
totalement différentes
en fait sur chaque album ça va être un
dessinateur puis un second dessinateur
sur le troisième ce sera encore un autre
dessinateur donc outre ce
ce très beau dessin vraiment un très
beau et très c'est surtout la place de
la femme dans cette révolution qui
finalement ont enfin déjà c'est une
révolution socialiste on parle dont on
parle très très peu et là surtout de la
place de la femme dans cette révolution
pour qu'on voit que finalement elles ont
été vraiment actrice et est preneuse
d'ordre aussi sur sur tous les
événements qui ont pu avoir lieu durant
cette révolution
donc je vous présente aujourd'hui une
bande dessinée jeunesse pour les enfants
à partir de 8 ans c'est une
autobiographie en fait l'auteur si si
belle et sourde
et lorsqu'elle était petite elle a
rencontré des difficultés pour avoir des
amis ça elle avait en fait un appareil
auditif et sa maîtresse posséder un
micro donc ça lui permettait d'entendre
ce que lui disait la maîtresse mais elle
avait des problèmes relationnels avec
les enfants parce qu'il se sentait tous
obligés soit articulé très fort ce qui
l'empêchait de comprendre ce qu'ils
disaient ou bien de parler beaucoup plus
fort et à ce moment-là ça ça coupait
l'articulation la particule à sion donc
pendant toute son enfance elle va avoir
cette quête un peu désespéré de trouver
la meilleure amie qui est pas ami avec
elle parce qu'elle est handicapée que ça
fait bien d'être ami avec une source pas
de faux amis qui se moque d'elle décalé
le dos tourné
et grâce à son appareil auditif et le
micro de la maîtresse que la maîtresse
garde toujours sur elle elle se découvre
un super pouvoir qui est celui
d'entendre tout ce que fait la maîtresse
même quand elle n'est pas dans la classe
par exemple la maîtresse donne un
contrôle de maths elle sort de la classe
pour aller faire pipi
si si qui se fait appeler désormais
super sourde l'entente d'aller aux
toilettes elle l'entend dans la salle
des profs
donc voilà elle développe ce super
pouvoirs elle en parle à ses camarades
et évidemment elle se fait plein d'amis
à ce moment là voilà ça une bd très
drôle à cette touchante aussi parce que
cette petite fille
elle est quand même un peu désespérée
dans une détresse elle a des parents qui
sont qui l'entourent vraiment beaucoup
elle a finalement des amis elle pensait
pas mais il ya des gens qui sont très
proches d'elle voilà c'est un beau roman
graphique sur la tolérance et sur
l'acceptation de la différence des
autres voilà c'est un très beau roman
sur une question d'éthique sur jusqu'où
se pose la limite de l'intérêt d'un
enfant vis-à-vis une question qui est
aussi crucial que sa vie donc c'est
l'histoire d'un juge des familles qui a
la responsabilité dans un procès de
juger ou non de la transfusion de cet
enfant enfants de témoins de jéhovah
dont les parents refusent totalement les
transfusions sanguines et qui pour m qui
pourrait en fait le sauver donc c'est
cette opposition entre tout ce côté
religieux et côté familial qui soit pub
qui s'oppose systématiquement à ces
transfusions sanguines et tout ce
problème moral et éthique vis-à-vis du
juge qui doit juger de cette enfant
mineure de savoir c'est est ce qu'on va
le sauver ou pas ou est ce qu'on va lui
imposer un choix ou est ce qu'il est il
a été fait ce qu'il a prises son libre
arbitre vis-à-vis de cette décision l'a
donc ce beau livre ce très beau livre ce
dernier roman la de ian mcewan
vraiment il est passionnant est vraiment
très très profond dans la question de ce
choix que va devoir que va devoir
prendre ce juge est dans voilà tout
l'articulation vis-à-vis de la société
vis-à-vis de son couple a elle aussi
vis-à-vis des choix qu'elle va devoir
faire et imposer vis-à-vis de cet enfant
donc pour ce pour ce choix là elle va
donc le rencontrer une seule fois et
c'est cette rencontre la décisive en
fait qui est vraiment centrale vis-à-vis
de ce roman il yal'avant rencontré
ensuite après cette rencontre où le
choix veuf va se décider
je vais pas vous raconter comment ça se
passe à la fin mais voilà cette
rencontre va permettre en fait de
décliner un choix par rapport à la
société par rapport à sa vie à elle et
par rapport à un choix éthique